[Musique]
bravo tu m'as retrouver ça que tu
cherches ne touche pas que nar qu'est ce
que tu fais la schl a tout de suite à
londres
tu vas pas tirer sur ta charmante amy
n'écoute pas butlins faut pas qu'ils
échappent
je ne peux pas
[Musique]
mon incident de police
c'est bon je crois que ma passion c'est
sainte bible si c'est pas la preuve
qu'il existe c'est celle là
maddon non
et moi qui mangeait trop de bonbons
croyable j'ai vraiment cru que c'était
la fin
[Musique]
augusta enfin et c'est bien toi c'est
bon je crois que je crois que ma bonne
vielle exit il écoute moi qui mangeait
trop de bonbons
la véritable morale de cette histoire
c'est toujours avoir de ventoline source
tu pourras ainsi profiter des choses
simples de la vie comme suivre golden
moustache sur les différents réseaux
sociaux et avec 3 ventoline tu pourra
regarder un max de vidéos inédites comme
celle du lab au et à partir de 4
ventoline rejoins-nous à ibiza pour
faire du saut en parachute avec john
sinapan tomlin